83 000 illegal aliens were apprehended
last week attempting to enter the U.S
illegally that is the largest number in
American history and of course by
definition we have no idea how many
successfully entered without being
apprehended so how is the White House
spinning The Invasion
things are going at the border sir much
better than much better than you all
expected do you have any plans today I
think
pardon me do you have any plans to visit
the Border
not in a near term no no just be
disruptive not anything else
no better than expected
and for once I think Joe Biden is
telling the truth the numbers were not
as he seems to imply lower than expected
border officials were bracing for
upwards of ten thousand illegal aliens
per day and the numbers exceeded that so
they weren't lower but they were better
than Biden expected because Biden along
with all the Liberals of the past
several decades hoped for and expected
huge migration numbers and now they've
gotten exactly what they wanted that's
why he looks so happy
the disconnect between Biden's reaction
and reality is not over the numbers
the disconnect is over the meaning of
the word better I'm Michael knowlesis
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show huge news
Miller Lite has joined its old pal bud
in coming out of the closet we will get
to that commercial in just a moment
first though
the situation at the border it cannot be
overstated what a disaster this is
it it seems as though this is a
perennial story and so it seems as
though it's news it's not news rather
and that is what the libs are counting
on the libs are counting on people
hearing conservatives pointing out the
chaos at the border saying oh well
they're always pointing the chaos out at
the border this is just always going on
it has never been like this
we are now looking at numbers that are
2x 3x
the old
unimaginably High numbers at the border
okay we we are in in a situation right
now in which Obama immigration officials
will say that 1 000 migrants Crossing
per day overwhelms the system and now
we're looking at four thousand six
thousand ten thousand illegal aliens per
day some of whom very clearly
are not only trying to violate the laws
of our nation to improve their own lives
some people are trying to violate the
laws of our nation to directly harm the
nation to commit acts of Terror border
patrol arrested an Afghan who's on the
terror watch list at the border U.S
border Patrol agents arrested this guy
uh in a group of migrants last week they
say we are Vigilant in our efforts to
detect and assess possible threats and
we work closely with our federal state
and local law enforcement Partners to
keep communities safe so there are two
conclusions we can draw here one is bad
and one is even worse the bad conclusion
we can draw is golly if U.S border
Patrol were able to apprehend this one
terrorist from Afghanistan trying to
sneak over the Border how many did they
not apprehend you've got ten thousand
people flooding over the Border more
than ten thousand people at the peak
over the last week so how many
terrorists made it through slip through
the fingers of law enforcement that's a
bad take
that's pretty scary
but here's the worst possibility
maybe they got the guy this is what the
libs will say they'll say look we always
get the really bad guys okay we
apprehend these terrorists at the border
no big DLC the immigration system's
working fine when we want to get a guy
we can zero in we can track him from
Afghanistan to Guatemala to Mexico to
wherever and we can get them at the
southern border
which means that the administration
can control the Border when it wants to
it just chooses not to
what that conclusion would imply is that
the government
is not being overwhelmed here by the
masses of human beings who are pouring
across no they actually have everything
totally under control and the chaos
you're seeing at the border is
intentional
these people these millions and millions
of illegal aliens are being permitted
into the country every year as part of
an intentional plan to undermine the
American political order and to change
the demographics of the country
ultimately the voting demographics of
the country
to change the whole way the country
operates to me that's much darker than
did some
two-bit terrorists sneak across the Rio
Grande that would be very bad but our
government just allowing this to happen
when when it's in full
full possession of the ability to stop
it that is much scarier and we know that
the government is corrupt because now
we've got the Durham investigation we've
got the conclusions of that years-long
investigation into the corruption of the
FBI and the doj and the Obama
Administration in beginning to spy on
Donald Trump's campaign back in 2016 and
the facts that they've found are damning
some of them are surprising we knew
things were going to be bad this is
worse than I expected actually and it's
even kind of funny the way this all
started
so according to the Durham report
the Clinton campaign
decided that it was going to smear
Donald Trump as a Russian asset
and the U.S intelligence Community
learned about the Clinton campaign's
plan to smear Donald Trump as a Russian
asset but apparently the U.S
intelligence Community learned about
this plan by overhearing Russian
intelligence discover the Clinton plan
to without any basis paint Donald Trump
as a Russian stooge
so according to ratcliffe's letter
quoted in the Durham report quote in
Late July 2016 U.S intelligence agencies
obtained insight into Russian
intelligence analysis alleging that U.S
presidential candidate Hillary Clinton
had approved a campaign plan to stir up
Scandal against U.S presidential
candidate Donald Trump by tying him to
Putin and the Russians hacking of the
Democratic National Committee
I love this idea that I'm not sure
exactly how it went down but I love the
idea of the CIA listening in and they
hear these Russians and they say have
you here crazy American woman Hillary
Clinton she is now saying that Donald
Trump is Russian stooge what where did
Hillary Clinton get idea that I do not
know but she said she's going to paint
depends a scandal and then the the CIA
is listening to this and the CIA or
whoever is listening I don't know who's
actually spying on these people it seems
like it's like that Mad magazine cartoon
you've got spies on spies on spies on
spies but
whichever agency it was you've got the
IC broadly the intelligence Community
broadly hearing this they know it's not
true they know that this is just some
nonsense cooked up by the Clinton
political campaign
so then what happens well we know what
happens on August 3rd 2016 within days
of receiving the Clinton plan
intelligence director of the CIA John
Brennan meets with
the vice president senior Administration
officials the Attorney General the FBI
director and the president himself Obama
is briefed by the CIA director in the
White House Situation Room to discuss
Russian election interference efforts
and they discuss the Clinton bogus
Scandal they're trying to Gin up against
Trump
according to John Brennan's handwritten
notes and his Recollections from the
meeting he briefed on relevant
intelligence
specific relevant intelligence including
the Clinton plan intelligence
specifically director Brennan's
Declassified handwritten notes reflect
the he briefed the meetings participants
regarding the quote alleged approval by
Hillary Clinton on July 26th of a
proposal from one of her campaign
advisors to vilify Donald Trump by
stirring up a scandal claiming
interference by the Russian Security
Services end quote we now have firm
proof that Not only was the Russia hoax
a hoax cooked up by Hillary Clinton
the most senior people in the American
government all knew it
the FBI the CIA the president they all
knew it and they all spied on Trump
anyway they all knew it and they all
spread the LIE through the media anyway
it was a complete
Witch Hunt and so when you see that when
you see that everybody was involved like
out of the craziest conspiracy theory
fever dream kind of movie screenplay
when you see everybody's involved
conservatives have to ask ourselves we
have to say
how can we trust the government agencies
we've got to restore some balance to our
government we've got to restore some
balance to our body that's why you got
to check out balance of nature right now
go to balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles living a healthy lifestyle is
not always easy especially when you're
always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure you're
getting the proper nutrition every day
which is why I'm a huge fan of balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to ensure you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients daily their capsules are
packed with 100 whole food that you can
take at any time balance of nature uses
a cold vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in whole fruits
and vegetables and encapsulates them for
easy consumption balance of nature sent
a bunch of their products down to the
studio for our team to try and we all
love them make fruits and vegetables a
part of your daily diet your body will
thank you if you want to be a hulking
Adonis like a little old me over here go
check it out go to balanceofnature.com
use promo code Knolls Canada wlas for 35
off your first order is a preferred
customer that is
balanceofnature.com promo code Knowles
for 35 off your first order make sure
you're getting those vitamins and
nutrients you need they taste great too
and unlike at the daily wire hopefully
around your home all those jackals won't
come and take them before you have the
chance to get your fill promo code knows
35 off your first order
it's a sad fact but conservatives simply
cannot trust the federal agencies
between what we learned from the Durham
report
and what we've just seen over the past
several years but from the Catholic
memoranda going around the FBI saying
we're going to infiltrate Catholic
churches we're gonna we're going to try
to cultivate priests as assets to spy on
their parishes because if you're a
traditional catholic and you go to the
Latin Mass can you imagine heaven for
fend why you're probably a threat you
might be a terrorist
we've got terrorists pouring across our
Southern border that that's fine maybe
we'll pick up one or two of them but the
ones we really got to focus on those
Catholics those Christians those parents
who don't want their kids to be
indoctrinated into critical race Theory
and gender theory in kindergarten
they're the real terror threat
how can we trust our own agencies we
know that they lie
to destroy us
and it's not even as though they cooked
up some plot to entrap or to just
baselessly smear some random Fringe
figure they did it to the Republican
nominee for president who later became
the Republican president
they'll do it to all of us speaking of
lawlessness in government
a Democrat Senator is now declaring a
popular Revolt if the Supreme Court
affirms the Second Amendment
if the Supreme Court eventually says
that states or the Congress can't pass
Universal background checks or can't
take these assault weapons off the
streets I think there's going to be a
popular Revolt over that policy a court
that's already pretty illegitimate is
going to be in full crisis mode
this is not just some talking head
pundit mouthing off on NBC News this is
a sitting U.S senator this is a Democrat
political leader saying you know I'll
tell you the Court's not legitimate one
of the three branches of government it's
not legitimate and so if they uphold the
American
tradition of self-protection and the
Second Amendment and the Constitution
I just think there's going to be a
popular revolt that's a nice Society you
got there space Courthouse you got there
it's a nice
Civil Society sure would be a shame if
there were a popular Revolt wouldn't it
Supreme Court I think you know what to
do talking like a mobster and this is
what they always do this is what they
did during BLM you're going to oppose
some of the radical BLM demands you're
not going to give zillions of dollars to
far left-wing groups to fund left-wing
politicians uh you're not going to
acquiesce to the leftist policies oh
it's a nice business you got sure would
be ashamed if something happened to it
it's what they always tell us
what Democrat Chris Murphy is calling
for here
is no less than an insurrection
and he's framing his advocacy of such a
thing as mere prediction but it's Not
Mere prediction because he's saying that
the Court's illegitimate the court has
lost legitimacy and I I tell you if I
were a Gambling Man I would imagine
there might be a popular revolt
the simple sentences that Chris Murphy
uttered on Meet the Press
are a far more serious type of
insurrection than anything that happened
around January 6th the worst day in the
history of politics it's not even close
and this is what they do this is what
they regularly do and this is why
very few things get me angry I'm pretty
even tempered very cool but when the
squishes take the bait and for every
stupid lie that they cook up about
Donald Trump they've been cooking up
one lie more Preposterous than the next
since the 2016 campaign all the way up
to the level of the CIA director and the
FBI director and the president of the
United States
when the squishes buy into this stuff
when they buy into the language around
the insurrection
give me a break the libs regularly call
for insurrections they just did so on
national TV I guess that's the
difference when the conservatives do an
Insurrection it's an eccentric horn hat
guy dancing around the capital rotunda
with police protection getting a private
tour of the capital it's a granny taking
a picture in the capital rotunda and
when the Democrats call for an
Insurrection they call for a popular
Revolt they support violence in the
streets and they do so on National
Television that's the difference
you know speaking of
constitutional rights and supposed
constitutional rights and president
Trump for that matter president Trump
I think he made a little bit of a
misstep and so in a spirit of friendship
and love and care I would encourage him
to maybe not go down the path that he
appears to be going down which is
president Trump is positioning himself
to the left of Ron DeSantis on the issue
of life and I think this is a huge
mistake
Trump was discussing the abortion ban
now the six-week abortion ban in Florida
that that Rhonda Santos is behind and
Trump said quote
he has to do what he has to do if you
look at what DeSantis did a lot of
people don't even know if he knew what
he was doing but he signed six weeks and
many people within the pro-life
Community feel that was too harsh
so just to correct the record as a
card-carrying member in good standing of
the pro-life community
nobody within the pro-life Community
thinks six weeks is too harsh we think
that six weeks is too lenient because a
person is a person no matter how small
and it's always wrong to murder people
and so if anything at all a six-week ban
is too lenient might be a good
incremental step in the right direction
but murder is either wrong or it isn't
and abortion either ends a human life or
it doesn't
and there's no way to meet in the middle
we've talked about this a lot with
transgenderism frankly it's even clearer
on the issue of abortion there were some
issues where we can find a conciliatory
middle ground and everybody can Kumbaya
and be happy on tax rates on immigration
policy on foreign policy on trade and
all sorts of things
but on a question like life
it's kind of a binary question can we
kill babies or not
should we murder innocent little babies
or not
if the baby is a baby if abortion ends a
human life then you shouldn't be allowed
to do it
if abortion does not end a human life if
the baby's not really a baby if it's
some other kind of thing it's a mere
clump of cells or is not a human or not
alive or whatever then there's no reason
that you should really limit abortion at
all this is why Hillary Clinton's answer
on abortion the safe legal and rare
answer on abortion is so silly
if abortion is murder then it shouldn't
be legal if abortion is not murder then
it should not be rare there's no reason
for it to be rare I think this is a huge
mistake for Trump too just politically
because Trump is the guy who overruled
Roe v Wade as he pointed out elsewhere
in that statement but that's what he's
gonna that's what he should run on he's
the greatest hero to the pro-life
movement that we've ever seen okay run
on it win it Americans are pro-life the
Republican base is very pro-life
why would you ever see that territory to
your
primary rival your Chief primary rival
when you've got the best record on it
it's a huge mistake to run to the left
of DeSantis the knock on DeSantis
campaign right now is that he has
support from people within the
establishment
it's not even necessarily desantis's
fault he's just he's not Trump he's the
biggest threat to Trump and so people in
The Establishment are more inclined to
support him so if you're Trump
you know that your base your guys are
the hardcore ones they're the
bloodthirsty ones they're the
paradoxically though on the issue of
Life they're actually the ones who who
don't want to to shed blood they're the
ones who are the great Defenders of life
so just go for it man you're Donald
Trump be Donald Trump don't don't meet
people in the middle okay especially on
something like life especially on
something that is that is the most
important aspect of your legacy
When Donald Trump is remembered he might
be remembered for a handful of things
but the chief accomplishment that man
has to his name the most important thing
that man has ever done in his life
is to appoint the judges
who overruled Roe v Wade who will over
the course of the years
hundreds of thousands millions of babies
will be saved because of what Donald
Trump did so run on it man don't see
that ground to DeSantis right now
DeSantis is being identified with the
culture War and the libs are Furious
about it Anna Navarro over on The View
you know that probably the most
intellectual Outlet on the left I'm
damning with faint praise but that's
probably what it is watched by lots of
people it's the highest rated show in
daytime Anna Navarro is claiming that
DeSantis he's a cynical opportunist he's
attaching himself like a parasite to
Manufactured culture wars now I know
when you're having a barbecue what you
need to do is attach that propane tank
to your grill that's why you got to
check out cinch right now go to
cinch.com use promo code Knowles the
weather is warming up in Nashville which
means that everyone's gearing up for
backyard barbecues and campfires the
last thing you need to be doing while
getting ready to host a barbecue is
driving around worrying about where to
refill your propane grill tank that is
why you need to check out cinch cinch is
a propane grill tank own delivery
service they deliver propane grill tanks
right to your door cinch delivers on
your schedule requires no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home track the order
on the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you are grilling steaks or lighting up
the patio heaters on a cold night
cinches propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment go online right
now to cinch.com or order the Cinch app
okay you download that app you can make
your orders new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
with promo code nulls can w-l-e-s that
is cinch.com or you get that cinch app
use promo code nulls kwles to get your
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
this is a limited time offer you must
live with an essential service area to
redeem it go to cinch.com
cynch.com offer for details
Ron DeSantis that opportunistic Ron
DeSantis that guy who's defending norms
and standards in schools that guy who's
protecting life on abortion that guy
that jerk you know what he's doing
according to Anna Navarro in The View
he's attaching himself like a parasite
to those manufactured culture War issues
that the uh the town hall last week
showed that a lot of people in the
Republicans base still really like
Trump's entertainment and and circus
um Rhonda Santos has a problem Rhonda
Santa's numbers have dropped drastically
since he won re-election in November I
think it's because he's attached himself
like a parasite to every single culture
manufactured culture War issue he can
and people particularly Floridians see
through it it's really kind of like an
old now drag queens Mickey Mouse AP
black history courses I mean it's just
crazy
so Anna Navarro is obviously wrong on
the facts
uh
Anna Navarro is before we get to the
manufactured culture work stuff she's
claiming that there's this big
distinction between Trump and DeSantis
in that DeSantis he's just this
manufactured culture War character
and Trump is not
Trump's not a culture War figure Trump
the guy who got Roe v Wade overruled
Trump the guy who launched his
presidential campaign by calling
Mexicans rapists at his hotel
that Trump
no he's not a culture War guy no he's a
regular bushy Country Club Republican
right
he launched his campaign by saying the
Mexicans crossing the border are rapists
and murderers and some I suppose are
good people no they're both culture War
figures
but then what about the manufactured
culture where the culture War has been
manufactured she's right about that
but the question you got to ask yourself
is manufactured by whom
did conservatives manufacture the
culture war did conservatives redefine
marriage for the for the first time ever
in this fundamental way did
conservatives redefine biology did
conservatives call for the Mass
Slaughter of little babies 800 000 per
year did conservatives call for the
eradication of our open border
bid conservatives or for the eradication
of our border making it an open border
did conservatives do this did
conservatives do that the culture War
is always instigated by the libs
necessarily we're conservatives
we like to conserve things
there's more to it than that but that's
broadly the way things go conservatives
tend to be
a little more normal a little more
well-adjusted a little happier a little
more content
it's always the libs who are shrieking
and screaming and trying to upend
everything
so they manufacture it
and then we respond to their
manufacturing and we try to stop them
from manufacturing it we try to export
it we try to get get it away whatever
whatever you guys are manufacturing we
don't want it okay
and then the libs accuse us of
of
manufacturing the thing they already
manufactured what is she talking about
she's talking about drag queens
Mickey Mouse AP black history courses so
she's talking about should perverts
twerk for little kids
no
they manufacture we say no thanks we
don't want it
Mickey Mouse should Disney push a not so
secret gay agenda the words of the
Disney exec's not mine
uh no no thank you we don't want that
and should students be taught in school
that white people are evil and America's
evil and the West is the worst place
ever under the guy is behind the facade
of black history no of course not
of course not now speaking of DeSantis
and education
DeSantis is
uh on on a tear when it comes to
education and he's pushing
a classical form of Education in Florida
schools
if you want to do things like gender
ideology go to Berkeley go to some of
these other places that's fine
it's fine
and there's nothing if that's what you
want to do there's nothing wrong with
that per se but for us with our tax
dollars we want to focus on the
classical mission of what a university
is supposed to be we don't want to be
diverted into a lot of these Niche
subjects that are heavily politicized we
want to focus on the basis and I think
what you've seen as these types of
majors and course first of all
how how employable are you with some of
these Majors I mean really it's um it's
not a good academic uh choice in terms
of being able to be employable that's
one of the reasons I think this whole
student loan thing University should be
on the hook for the student loans if
that were the case they would make sure
that their curriculum was really fit to
be productive for the students when they
graduate
great stuff I love it this is an
important tactic to use one education as
a subject is very important but the
tactic is important here too we've got
to go after the liberal power centers
universities are one of them how do we
go after them we put them on the hook
for student loans how do we go after
them we tax those endowments how do we
go after them we
we attack their centers of power
basic stuff DeSantis is totally right
about it my only disagreement with him
here is that he says look if you want to
teach crazy gender stuff in Berkeley
that's fine but we're not going to do
that in Florida my only disagreement
with him is it isn't fine in California
either
I get that we've got a list of
priorities okay we've gotta we've got to
get the wins that we can first but we
shouldn't grant them that premise oh you
can have California no the libs don't do
that it's not fine to teach this crap in
California either it's not fun to teach
it in New York either
the libs never seed ground they never
say look if you want to not acknowledge
this ridiculous transgender ideology in
Tennessee that's fine if you don't want
to radically redefine marriage in Texas
that's fine if you don't want to have
marauding gangs all over your streets in
Florida that's fine no
the libs push Nationwide
to redefine the fundamental building
block to chop up little kids bodies to
defund the police to this that and the
other thing they don't they don't
respect the state borders
and frankly we shouldn't either this
stuff is really bad we are countrymen
with The Californians and we should
endeavor
through appropriate and just means while
respecting principles such as
subsidiarity and federalism we should
Endeavor to get this stuff out of
California too sometimes the best
defense is a good offense you've got to
give yourself a little bit of
ideological breathing room okay
this is what aroused so much higher at
my CPAC speech it's one of the reasons
that they lied about me all the way up
to the White House and and put words
into my mouth is because they were
horrified by the Plain words that I did
say which is no we're not going to fight
the transgender battle over should it be
eight year olds or nine-year-olds being
trans we're going to fight it over
whether transgenderism is real or not
and by the way it's not real and we need
to eradicate the whole ideology from
public life that puts the libs on their
heels and so now all of a sudden they've
got to defend transgenderism and while
they're defending transgenderism they're
not trying to trans the seven-year-olds
they're fighting a a an earlier battle
same thing goes for Education if we go
on the offense and we say now we're
going to pass laws to make it illegal to
teach this gender crap or race hate or
whatever stuff they're teaching in
California we're going to do it in their
states every second that they're
fighting that issue every dollar they
spend trying to defend critical race
theory in California that's that's a
moment that's a dollar that they're not
spending trying to push their ideology
onto you in Tennessee and Texas and
Florida
speaking of
speaking of these viral communicable
diseases that's how that's how I view
liberalism now it's like a it's like a
communicable disease that we just need
to contain the way that we contain
Communism the way we contain a pandemic
but speaking of virality
this is the most troubling story I've
seen all week and it has nothing to do
with the Border or the 2024 race or any
of that
has to do within
Instagram lady it has to do with a
social media influencer she's 23 years
old she's got 1.8 million followers on
Snapchat alone to say nothing of the
other social media platforms
her name is Karen Marjorie and she has
created a chat bot
her chat bot is called chat or Karen a i
and users of this chat bot pay one
dollar per minute to speak to a robot
that pretends to be her
and in the first week of its beta test
this woman made seventy thousand dollars
I'm looking over at my producer Ben
Davies over we're in the wrong line of
work we oh man I should have just been a
young hot chick and then can you imagine
how much especially one with nerd techie
friends because then you don't actually
have to do anything
at all you can Outsource even
social media
thirst traps you can Outsource even that
to an algorithm
now what does this gal say she says
Karen A.I will never replace me Karen AI
is simply just an extension of me an
extension of my Consciousness because
her schtick is that she amasses all
these followers with these young lonely
men who
presumably you don't have girlfriends or
don't care about their girlfriends very
much and so they're chatting with this
Phantom of a human being over
Snapchat over Instagram DMs
and this is how she makes her money and
becomes popular but there were too many
guys so she just outsourced it to a
robot
she says Karen AI is going to come fill
that Gap she says that Karen AI might
cure loneliness quote whether you need
somebody to be comforting or loving or
you just want to rant about something
that happened at school or at work Karen
AI will always be there for you this is
the saddest thing I've read in a very
long time
but it's working she thinks that this
that this
operation could make her millions of
dollars of not only a month maybe a week
who knows 70 grand in the beta test
that's unbelievable
and it and it might
why does this work though it doesn't
just work because of the new technology
it works because of the way Society
already operates
this is what's so damning about the
whole thing this is what's so depressing
the reason that this chat bot thing
works is because the chat bot isn't all
that different from regular modern
social interaction
so much regular modern social
interaction is shallow
transactional
and virtual
so shallow in that
we don't
we don't treat one another as Eternal
beings
with whom we're endeavoring to create a
life and to learn something about
reality and to build something up
together and to have children no one's
having children no one's getting married
it's transactional the modern dating
culture is is a hookup culture
it's it's like out of an EIN Rand novel
you just you don't you don't lay down
with somebody because you love this
person and this person's your spouse and
you're open to life and you're gonna
have a big family and a good life no you
just do it because okay I want to feel
good tonight and you're reasonably
pleasing to me and hopefully the same is
true in the other direction so we'll do
that but no strings attached no nothing
we certainly won't have kids we won't
get married and a lot of it's just
virtual my friends who are on the dating
apps I missed the dating apps because
sweet little Elise and I got back
together just when that was starting to
come out so I've never been on them but
my friends are on them
all they ever really do is just send
messages occasionally they'll go on
dates I guess but
those of you who are on dating apps know
this better than I do second hand
so much of the time you spend with
dating apps is just on the app just
messaging even when you're off the app
what are you doing you're just texting
people it's all just virtual so what's
the difference
when I'm in the room with a real human
being
I can I can still to today tell the
difference between a human being and a
robot but if you're just texting with
somebody if all you want to do is just
get your jollies off or rant or complain
or whatever
what is the difference between Karen A.I
and Karen Marjorie a 23 year old
Snapchat girl
practically speaking there isn't one now
if you're looking for something
interesting to watch and you don't want
to just talk to robots all the time you
got to check out our series what we saw
hosted by Storyteller Bill Whittle
season one is focused on Apollo 11 and
now season two of what we saw as in full
swing this time Bill pays a bleak
picture of the growing existential
threat to America due to Soviet Russia
and Cuba
in episode 10 we are transported to
Vietnam in the Gulf of Tonkin where
North Vietnamese torpedo boats attack
the USS Maddox plunging us further into
the Cold War how big a price will we pay
in our efforts to prevent communism from
spreading outside of Vietnam Bill makes
you feel like you're there witnessing
history new episodes of The Cold War
come out every week but you've got to be
a member to see it go to dailywire.com
Cold War to start watching
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Old School hey it's been a while since
we've seen a comment from Old School
comment is
it's foolish to think that people who
are willing to break the law in order to
enter the country will also be willing
to follow the law when they get here
so true I really like that because
politics
is both much more complicated than
people pretend that it is and also
paradoxically much simpler
there are all sorts of details to fill
in and nuances but it's pretty much just
that Ronald Reagan said it very well
he was asked about illegal immigration
he said illegal immigration is illegal
it's not that complicated
the kind of people that you attract when
you don't enforce the law
they're criminals and so you're you're
not getting your best to quote Donald
Trump
they're not sending their best okay
now the most important story of the day
I don't want to forget about immigration
forget about the economy collapsing
forget about the bank runs forget about
World War III
I want to congratulate Miller Lite
Miller Lite
is following its own truth
it's going against
the conservative cancel knob okay it's
standing up Miller Light
is at least as gay
as Bud Light take it away
here's a little known fact women were
among the very first to brew beer ever
from Mesopotamia to the Middle Ages to
colonial America women were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later how
did the industry pay homage to the
founding mothers of beer they put us in
bikinis
look at this wild it's time beer made it
up to women so today Miller Lite is on a
mission to clean up not just their the
whole beer Industries
Miller Lite has been scouring the
internet through all this and buying it
back so that he can turn it into good
for women Brewers literally good how you
ask ladies take it away first we turn
the badge into compost now we feed
compost to worms pushed out beautiful
fertilizer
that good helps Farmers grow quality
hops
which has been donated to women Brewers
to make their own really good
but there's definitely more out
there in your attic in the garage and
your parents basement send any you got
into Miller Lite and they'll turn that
into good too
oh so here's to women because without us
there would be no fear
[Music]
this is the Cleopatra of Bud Light
commercials this is
Miller Lite is now the Netflix of
Brewers
actually did you know beer was invented
by women
I mean it wasn't but we're but let's
just say so did you know actually
Cleopatra was black I can't wait for the
next documentary from Netflix on George
Washington starring Spike Lee it's going
to be really great
this is it so okay there's this
historical claim
is that beer was invented by women or
has been produced by women for centuries
or whatever which is obviously not true
if you're going to give credit to any
group I guess you should give it to
monks right well then it the monks who
really began brewing and popularizing
beer okay fine
then you get to the next level which is
in the past
we've sold beer by putting pictures of
pretty women in bikinis on our
advertisements and that was terrible so
now we're going to put very angry
feminists
very very sort of frumpy clothing that's
how we're gonna sell beer to our
customer base that's totally going to
convince them
and then the third part which irritates
me frankly even more than the first two
which is
women saying
that we
we love to say naughty language you know
if I say s-h-i-t that's that's gonna
make me cool and hip it's like all these
female comedians who just think if they
talk about their genitals and say some
four-letter words that's a a
substitute for a joke and for comedy
it's not
it's not at all Miller Lite huh you know
what I say Miller Light in the loafers
is what they are these days
I'll see myself at now good night
everybody now it's it's
differently woke than the Bud Light
commercial and I should point out the
the Miller Lite commercial came out
before the Bud Light commercial and no
one noticed it and people are only
noticing it now after the big backlash
so I'm sure Miller executives are doing
their best to try to downplay this
commercial I bet it was Bud Light
opposition researchers who found this
for Miller and they're popularizing this
right now
but
it it's differently woke the Bud Light
commercial the Bud Light can with Dylan
Mulvaney was woke in that it was
adopting this radical new anthropology
so it was positioning itself as fun and
happy in light
with Miller you're seeing the flip side
of wokeness or the flip side of
liberalism that's all it really is she's
the basic old word which is they're
really negative angry side the side of
resentment the side with a chip on its
shoulder it's the same practical effect
which is insulting the people who
actually buy these beers
but you're seeing both sides
there's the happy glitzy facade and then
the underlying angry reality of it as
I've said before though I'm not worried
about Miller Lite now no I can't drink
Miller Lite or oh no I can't drink Bud
Light
because I prefer to drink white claw
when I'm drinking a canned alcohol and
white Claw is already so gay that it
will never have to prove its liberal
Bona fides by pandering to the wokies or
by insulting it's customer base which is
great I love that I get to drink my
mango
hard Seltzer in peace
speaking of the
plans of of the wokies
the revolution goes marching on we don't
have time really to get into this yeah
so I'll just tease it you know I've been
teasing you for the past week or so
there's a headline from The New York
Times why some companies are saying
diversity and belonging instead of
diversity and inclusion
you know diversity equity and inclusion
that was for the past five or six years
that's been the slogan used by the
liberal apparatchex whose job it is in
universities and companies to stir up
trouble and uh
insult white people and insult men and
and make everybody angry with one
another so they're changing the term
as they always change the term
the old one is diversity and inclusion
the new one is diversity and belonging
the New York Times wasted so many words
explaining why this is I know exactly
why this is I actually wrote a book
about why this book is called speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
we'll get into that story along with
several others tomorrow now though you
can see if you're watching the show
right now I am on the road I'm very very
excited I'm here in sunny California
my producer Mr Ben Davies has brought
the iPad on the road so I'll get to chat
with you in the segmentum and bro room
it's the new way we're declining that
phrase and we've got an extra story okay
we've got an extra story here that Ben
Davies has picked at I have not read it
yet so I will bring to bear all of my
Acumen all of my insight and I will chat
with you if you're not a member yet you
go to dailywire.com Knowles
these promo code nulls get two months
free on an annual plan we'll see you at
the segmentum membrane
[Music]